la sûreté du québec a saisi une voiture
et un bateau appartenant à steven chabot
l'un des quatre hauts gradés de la est
ce qu accusé de fraude selon un
affidavit obtenues par radio-canada les
indemnités de départ controversé prise à
même un fonds secret n'ont pas été
déclarés en plus à l'impôt christian
latreille avec honnêteté et justice
l'ex-directeur général de la securitate
des chaînes et son adjoint steven chabot
ainsi que l'ex haut gradé jean audette
et l'inspecteur alfred tremblay sont
accusés de vol fraude et abus de
confiance
on leur reproche de s'être pays des
indemnités de départ a même une pièce
secrète réservé aux enquêtes criminelles
l'affidavit que nous avons obtenu est
signé par l'enquêteur laurent roberge
il expliqué je cite que le 17 mars 2010
steven chabot a demandé au contrôleur
est là et ce qu de préparer deux
formulaires davance pour des dépenses
spécial d'opération
la première en son nom et la deuxième au
nom d'alfred tremblay monsieur chabot a
par la suite rapporté les deux demandent
aux contrôleurs dûment signé par lui
même
richard deschesnes et alfred tremblay en
lui demandant de garder secret
l'enquêteur roberge ajoute qu après
l'analyse de 9 ans tente enfin d'emploi
visant d'expo gradé de la ssq seul les
cas de steven chabot et alfred tremblay
ont nécessité des dépenses spécial
d'opération
le conseil du trésor confirme que
chacune de ces ententes
or dit faire l'objet d'une autorisation
gouvernementale
selon la fidh a vite ses 167 1931
dollars qui auraient été versés de
laquelle secrète de la est ce qu aux
comptes conjoints de steven chabot le 19
mars 2010 le même jour à l'aide d'un
chèque visé de 68 mille dollars
il aurait acheté un véhicule infiniti au
nom de sa conjointe
quelques jours plus tard l'ex haut gradé
chabot aurait remboursé un prêt de 46
mille dollars contracté pour l'achat
d'un bateau ainsi qu'un autre près de
12000 dollars à la banque laurentienne
qui a servi à acquérir le véhicule
récréatif
selon la fidl vit toujours seven chabot
n'a pas déclaré ces sommes dans ses
déclarations de revenus l'avocat de
steven chabot maître jean claude hébert
affirme que la fille david n'est pas
fidèle aux propos tenus
par l'ensemble des témoins rencontrés
par les enquêteurs
je vous rappelle que les quatre
policiers accusés ont plaidé non
coupable ici christian latreille radio
canada montréal